cher monsieur bel abbès comme tous les
ans vous avez fait une demande de
participation au salon de l'agriculture
micmacs laquelle la direction du salon à
10h et où vous habitez vous et votre
pays d'accueil
pour faire marcher tu appelles
montserrat c'est pourtant celui son beau
frère
non non non tam est avachi constate
également un lecteur d'acheter sa couche
regarde moi ça un vocaliste ap toujours
des cauchemars
vous savez écrire oui on détache et ma
chérie à n'ont pas mâché ses mots si ma
femme
nontron même il s'appelle fatah bel
abbès et depuis plus de 20 jours il
traverse la france écoutez bien à pied
on ne voit que me farthouat donné six
photographes qui passa dirigeante est
devenu une star
tous souffrent à l'eau avant le début du
concours qui ne pourra participer on est
sur le périphérique à sa bouche un peu
avant à tarder qu'est ce que je fous là
pas une campagne avec guillaume canet
et comme on dit qui veut voyager loin et
là j'étais loin que